so I've been asked to choose in an
amendment that I think is important and
valuable and so I think the first
amendment and it's not only because it's
the first amendment it's what it says
and it says Congress shall make no law
respecting an establishment of religion
or prohibiting the free exercise thereof
or abridging the freedom of speech or of
the press or the right of the people
peaceably to assemble and to petition
the government for a redress of
grievances and I think from the
Constitution this sets up the rest of
the Constitution about what it means to
be an American citizen and the value of
our individual liberties because it sets
us apart as individuals we have the
right to speech we have the right to
Association we have the right to
religion we can think we can act we can
associate freely and as a scholar of
international relations when you pull
people around the world and they ask us
what is it that you think is most
important about the United States that
you think sets the United States apart
more often than not people point to the
First Amendment and to the freedom of
speech the freedom of assembly the
freedom of religion as first and
foremost what makes the United States
special that we privilege individuals as
citizens and our Constitution protects
that we need to keep that in mind as
citizens and I have to tell you around
the world people acknowledge that and
respect that about the United States you
know I really have a hard time with this
so so this idea of freedom of assembly
and freedom of speech regardless of the
nature of that speech I mean there are
exceptions to that about whether it
promulgates violence or potentially
promulgates violence and I tend to come
down on the liberal side that people
should have freedom of speech and that
as you know defender of the you know the
First Amendment of the Constitution that
then you need to redouble your efforts
to make sure that there's a if you fear
that this is going to lead to violence
conflict that you redouble your efforts
and have police and you make arrests and
you said you've overstepped your
boundaries so I tend to be somebody let
them assemble
let them have their freedom of speech
and redouble your efforts and take
measures to ensure that that can happen
[Music]
you